the oceans are where all life on earth
began for years though humanity has just
used them as a rubbish bin we've all
seen the impacts of plastics and
thankfully we're beginning to make
changes to address that problem there
are complex issues beneath the surface
that can feel almost too daunting to
tackle however pioneering researchers
are working right now to ensure a
healthy future for our oceans acts are
supporting researchers were expanding
the boundaries of our knowledge and it's
incredible in this film we'll be
exploring the potential we all have to
play a part in saving the oceans but
before that let's have a look at one
more entrancing fish now cut to me
talking to a real-life marine expert my
name is Cosima Portis I'm a researcher
at the University of Exeter and I study
how fish sense their environment and how
they respond to environmental change
house acts are helping research their
important work access funded my work to
look at the effects of ocean
acidification on economically important
fish species the publicity that's been
done around single-use plastics that
need sort of permeated our consciousness
and we're now trying to reduce that but
is acidification a bigger underlying
problem yes it's something we can't see
and the oceans are doing us a huge favor
they're storing about 25 percent of the
carbon dioxide in our atmosphere but in
the process the oceans are becoming more
acidic and what we're finding is that
it's affecting the behavior of fish how
does their behavior change
well I found that their sense of smell
is being affected if you're going diving
or snorkeling and visibility is quite
poor it's similar for a fish and they
can use their sense of smell to find
mates find food avoid predators and
therefore if their sense of smell is
affected their lives are affected as
well it's a much wider issue than fish
not being able to smell properly yes
it's about food security isn't it yeah
and about all sorts of sort of wider
ethical issues exactly it's just another
stressor on top of fish being overfished
and having to deal with an increase in
temperature and AXA
goes beyond just supporting us
financially it's allowed me and other
researchers to tell the public about our
work and also put us in contact with
charities and members of parliament to
talk to them about these issues to
enable fish to smell properly yeah we
just need to try and reduce our co2
Prince I'm Emily pen and I'm working on
solving the ocean plastic pollution
crisis
what's your engagement with the ocean I
mean obviously you're an explorer but
there has a there is a message behind
what you do I get to spend my life at
sea but it's actually about the plastic
issue and so what I'm doing now is
taking other people out there so they
can have the same experience firsthand
but also do the important scientific
work alongside it that we need to
properly understand both the impacts and
where the solutions lie and solving the
problem so what would you say are sort
of mediate solutions that you'd come
across the more time I spend at sea the
more I realize how much the solutions
start on land yes because a lot of the
time I think it's out of sight out of
mind what we talk about a lot now is
actually micro plastics so all of the
plastic that's leaving land 8 million
tons a year fragments and the UV rays
from the Sun caused those bigger bits of
plastic to photo degrade to break down
into what we then call micro plastics
and they're now forming a soup over the
surface of our ocean how can we stop the
toxic soup really our opportunity right
now is on land at the store get it in
the water
exactly better still stop using it and
you're setting off on a big new mission
so this next big project is about
solutions based science
oh that was so yes so solutions focus
science we all know there's a problem we
need to understand better what the
problem is
the fact that the plastic is so small
and that it's sinking and then building
an army of people who've had this
experience oh here we go again
now this beauty as I've been up top has
been badgering me for food so beautiful
well if you ever want anyone to join the
army or to be on one of your boat
seasick as I get I'd be delighted
anything I can do to help change yeah
that's great news yep I'm Helen Ann
Smith I'm a journalist at sky news and I
was part of the original sky ash and
rescue team so what was the inciting
incident what what prompted this
extraordinary campaign we went to
Bermuda well we were there we were sort
of like god this there really is a lot
of plastic on the beaches here it's just
shocking this paradise you absolutely
can't ignore it I've stood in a room
where the entire space was covered with
plastic they've been taking out the
stomach of a whale so what kind of
impact is the campaign has within a year
the Scotland said they were going to
introduce bottle deposit schemes which
is a scheme where you take your bottle
back to where you got it every
individual person can make such a
massive difference by making what is
really small choices you know what buyer
you've reusable water bottle try and
choose fresh food that's kind of
packaged in sort of paper rather than
plastic and you know what consumers need
to put pressure on politicians and on
companies you know you need to write to
your MP and you need to say I care about
this you need to do something about it
and then it's important much as we talk
about the power of the consumer and how
we can change the world we can also
destroy the world for some reason
because it's this big blue deep thing
that we can't see very much people have
this mental block over the fact that
we're doing such damage to it you know
the sky and rescue it has I hope really
had an impact in making people think
about the way that they use this
material and try and think about it as a
permanent material and not a throwaway
material you always needed a campaign
like this to focus minds yeah on a
simple fix that can be done domestically
I think people do want to do the right
thing ultimately and I hope that this
will continue to snow genuinely think
that people want to do good
I mean climate change is sort of it's
very easy to think we just head into
water an together and there's nothing I
can do as an individual it's doomed ever
things it's over but presumably your
work is leading you to a positive
conclusion or that there is some hope
we're not there yet and we can do
something about it AXA Research Fund is
creating a community of researchers and
we have a chance to interact and tell
other people about it the better or
worse human beings have ended up as a
sort of custodians of nature that's
right here and there's an ethical
dimension isn't there about making sure
that life began in the ocean we should
try and allow that to continue exactly
is it too late I don't think so thank
God we just need to act now we're
beginning a journey to save life on this
incredible planet I felt that it might
be too late to address the balance that
maybe we've pushed things beyond the
point of no return but I've learned
today that with the innovations and
science made possible by AXA funded
research we can still alter this course
let's be brave enough to push for change
from our politicians our corporations
and ourselves if we decide to take
action then anything is possible to
build a better future we need to speak
up now and if we do we'll step into a
future that's better for all of us